no day but today so I've got a
confession to make
I like rent I like the music I like the
show it was honestly that soundtrack was
one of my go-to albums when I was in
high school I liked it quite a bit and
I've noticed that over time there's been
kind of a building backlash maybe too
strong a word but a building inclination
of people to do takedowns and explain
why rent isn't good or what's wrong with
it or things of that nature and I kind
of want to address those because I think
they're tied into one specific thing
that is a problem but I think people
have the wrong headspace about it so a
couple things about rent first of all if
for some reason you're watching this you
don't really know rent rent it was a
Broadway show that came out in the 90s
about a bunch of bohemian characters
living are squatting more accurately in
in a building and sort of what they're
going through it's it's an it's an
update of La bohème but instead of half
the characters having tuberculosis half
the characters have HIV or AIDS so it's
just a story of a roughly about a year
of their lives or so kind of well first
act is one night and then the second act
sort of jumps across time as it goes
along and as I said I have noticed a or
at least within the YouTube circles that
I circulate a surprising at least to me
number of videos takedowns diatribes
rants going on about how garbage rent is
and
I think they're wrong or at least the
criticisms that they're 11 leveling are
being unfairly applied and first let me
say if you don't like rent and it's
because of things like I just don't like
the style a music fine that's totally
valid but what I'm going to address here
are the sorts of things that I've seen
folks do when you know trying to
quantify a reason basically when people
do these sort of take down videos
they're they may say they're giving a
reason why they don't like rent more
often than not it feels like they're
giving a reason why nobody should like
rent some of them get a little more high
on their horse than that than others but
that's the vibe that you get and the
arguments being applied aren't
subjective arguments they're not well I
don't like the music well I don't you
know like this or that it is well
there's this thing there's this thing
about this story about these characters
and it's wrong it's bad it's a bad
message it's I'm expected to root for
these people it's things along those
lines and like I said I think it's uh
it's unfair and I'll explain why so the
first thing that I point out and I think
part of the reason this has been
happening I think at least from my
perspective in the last decade or so is
because the movie came out and I think
that's not to say that nobody disliked
rent back when it was just a stage play
and a Broadway soundtrack but I think it
became a lot easier to criticize once
there was a movie because when it comes
to something that's a play it's
difficult to criticize anything other
than the specific performance that you
saw it is difficult to to criticize the
thing as a whole unless there are like
massive glaring fundamental flaws in it
because do you don't know if you just
saw a bad performance you can't count on
your audience having the same point of
reference you can't count on them having
seen a you know having well seen it at
all if the
whether it be on Broadway or in a or in
a touring show or even like a local well
staged production of it you can't count
on them having seen that so when you try
and do a takedown of a play well your
audience doesn't have the frame of
reference you do they may 12th they may
not have seen it all all right all or if
they have there's absolutely no
guarantee that what they saw was what
you saw film totally different game
you know when talking about a film that
anyone who's seen it saw what you saw
maybe they don't have the same takeaways
maybe they don't have the same reactions
to it but at the very least the base
level and where you start is the same
everybody saw the same movie and so I
think that is why we started to see more
of these criticisms come about after the
movie cuz suddenly there was a point of
reference that people who didn't like
Brent could all point to and go there
okay now you can see what I'm talking
about without having to pay to go to New
York and see it on Broadway but like I
said the the criticisms the common
criticisms that I see about this
generally have to do with arguments
about the the characters how they act
how they behave their values and that
the show is expecting audiences to
sympathize and to at the very least like
that and a lot of these takedowns
basically go through lists of why these
are unlikable horrible people and so
some of the criticisms that you get so
you get things along the well I think in
many ways it's encapsulated by the
character of Benny who in the film is
played by Taye Diggs who was also part
of the original cast I'll be coming back
to that element it's kind of a big part
of where I'm going with this but Benny
is portrayed within the story of rent
basically as a sellout he you know all
these people were friends for a while
and they've all got artistic ambitions
you know you've got a songwriter and a
dancer and you've got a sort of
philosophy professor in you've got a
would-be filmmaker and a musician so all
these people have these artistic ideal
for what they're gonna do with their
lives and Benny is basically he's
married into money and now he's working
on corporate izing gentrifying and
otherwise sort of bringing in financial
stability and he's offering them a
chance to from their perspective sell
out as well and so when you get the
criticisms of rent these days what you
get is Benny is not a bad guy Benny is
is like the most reasonable person here
and all these other people they like
they want to live rent-free in a
building and like they they leave stable
stable positions in order to pursue
things that are never gonna work like
these people are stupid and selfish and
self righteous and self-important
they're so convinced of their own genius
like these people aren't sufferable how
could anybody like them and I think
that's a valid criticism of the movie
but not to play and that may seem like
an odd statement because the movie
changes virtually nothing there's a
couple of tiny tweaks and a couple of
cuts songs but nothing substantially has
changed from the plate of the movie and
one of the point they brought back the
original cast but that's actually where
they caused the problem and that's not
to say that the original cast is bad
original cast is great but by bringing
them back for the film that caused or at
least opened the door to the problem
because it was about a decade and what
that means is the various things that
have talked about these characters over
idealizing their artistic ambitions
seeing seeing the idea of seeking
stability as selling out those are the
perspectives in the play of people in
their 20s and let's be honest when
you're in your 20s a lot of us are kind
of dumb because we've gotten through our
teens and now we we survived that and
now we think we know how everything
works or we think we can bend the world
to make it work the way we want it to
work but as you
get older I think a lot of us tend to
grow out of this stuff and when these
sorts of points of view are being
espoused by people in their 20s you can
I mean some people may still not like it
but personally I think that makes a big
difference between that and people in
their 30s behaving in this same way
because if you're in your 30s and to
single out the character of mark as a
good go-to he he is the aspiring
filmmaker and he's been trying to make
he Kelly calls it his film he's been
trying to make something for a while and
he basically accidentally stumbles into
a steady paying job with the 90s
equivalent of TMZ and it pays well but
he doesn't enjoy it it's soul soul
sucking and he quits that job to work
full-time on his film that has no
distribution he is no guarantee that he
will finish it anyone will ever watch it
or I'll ever make any money off of it
for someone in their 20s to do that it
may still not be a good decision but
somebody that young like this is the age
to try in your 20s is the age to make a
go of it because you're young enough to
to be in the best position to bounce
back to have the energy and to have the
drive to recover if this fails and so
when somebody in their 20s is like nah
man I'm gonna focus full-time on my film
like again from a macro point of view
you may still be going that's kind of
dumb but you kind of feel like going
okay you know what best of luck to you
dude when a guy in his 30s quits a
steady paying job in order to basically
cut together his home movies that's not
a Deering that's insane and that age
jump on almost all the characters
because there were a couple who were
recast for the film but almost all the
characters are now visibly in their 30s
instead of in their 20s and if the if
these ideas that I'm talking about them
having in their eye in their
idealization and other
stuff if it seems weird that I'm saying
it's more acceptable at one age than
another I think a lot of times in
criticism people latch on to concepts in
stories and don't consider the actual
source and by source I don't mean the
story I mean what character what
circumstance is that actually coming out
of I think a good recent example of that
is kylo Ren in the last Jedi again I
don't really like the last Jedi but the
problems I have are not the problems
that it seems like the most vocal
detractors of that film seem to have for
the most part but a lot of people
latched on to kylo ren's line of let go
of the past kill it if you have to and
you know people are going and this is
what Ryan Johnson's doing with the movie
he's saying we have to kill our love of
Star Wars and I'm like okay wait hold on
if you want to make that argument you
want to back it up substantively with
things throughout the film fine but if
you're lacking on to only that one line
does it matter to you at all that it's
being said by the bad guy somebody who
we have every reason to inherently
distrust is that really what you you
really think the message of a film is
being carried by the villain I'm not
saying that's impossible I'm not saying
that never happens but like there's a
reason that philosophy was put into the
mouth of a character we have every
reason to distrust I think um I started
thinking about this more this was a
while back I first saw this but when
Kevin Smith was doing his sort of his
speaking tours of colleges and stuff and
he got into a conversation during a Q&A
section with a student at one of the
colleges he went Matt talking about his
film chasing Amy
now if you haven't seen chasing Amy
broadening me real short I'm basically a
woman who previously identified that as
a lesbian begins dating a man and
there's a lot of other stuff going on
but that's the main thrust of and that's
what the conversation was about and the
the student asked him don't you feel
that the way you presented all of this
is that she at the end of the day just
needed she quotes the term used in the
movie which is to expose
for me to say on this channel because I
like to keep it clean but aren't you
basically saying she just needed to be
with a man and what Kevin Smith pointed
out was that that specific sentiment
that she they you know that the student
paired it back in the exact words from
the film that sentiment is spoken by a
character in the film who is
demonstrably wrong about everything
like he's always wrong and he's kind of
a jerk and Kevin Smith made the point of
saying like there's a reason I gave that
line to that character now you could
still make an argument that the film as
a whole is still you know pushing
forward that message in that there's
other problematic elements to it and
that's fine but it it really does make
the point who says something and the
details of that character make a lot of
difference which brings me back to rent
again because the way that these
characters are living for people in
their 20s
well I'm again I'm not saying
necessarily some grand heroic thing
there is something endearing about how
optimistic they are about the impact
they're gonna leave on the world about
what their art can mean about how they
could possibly live their lives reality
is likely going to beat that out of them
over the course of their lives we don't
see that in the play necessarily or the
film but you can kind of presume that
when you see characters in their 20s
acting dumb I think sometimes people go
well that's stupid they should know this
this this and this I'm like you're
saying that from the perspective of
somebody who has lived past that and who
does know better and they haven't gotten
there yet but you give you give these
same trace somebody in their 30s and
suddenly you're going why are you in
your 30s and you haven't realized that
this isn't going to work because that's
the thing the characters in their 20s
yes they haven't realized that the way
they're trying to live probably is not
gonna work out for them long term but
that's the thing they're in their 20s
they haven't had enough experiences to
know for certain and feel confident that
that is the lesson that they have
learned if they learn it at all where is
somebody in their 30s they should have
learned that by now and if they weren't
gonna adjust their lives accordingly at
the very least we should be they should
not be acting as naive now I'm not
saying there's no like bohemian
lifestyle people in their 30s or 40s or
even older I've met some of them but
when they get to that age they usually
at the very least have a more realistic
outlook on how they live their lives and
don't have this bizarre naive
idolization you know they're living
their lives how they want to but the
naivete that at the very least that
sheds if not a complete outlook on life
sheds over the course of a decade from
your 20s to your 30s as you just live
and yeah these points of view become
harder to sympathize with in these
characters become more unlikable if
they're this age and acting this way
then if they're in their 20s and acting
this way I mean heck think about any
teenage comedy especially like the
teenage sex comedies most of which have
aged very badly and are very problematic
but like even setting that aside think
about how weird a lot of those things
would be if these characters weren't
teenagers but were 25 35 45 and again
you know yes I know things like 40 year
old virgin virgin basically ran with
that concept but that that was an
attempt at subverting the whole thing
but just think about if something like
American Pie without like maybe with
removing the losing virginity element
but imagine the the plot of American Pie
being we're all going to have sex with
these people we've selected by X date
you know towards the end of the year
coming from people
honestly any older than teen years
that's creepy that's weird coming from
teenagers again you know I understand
it's now problematic and all that but
like coming from teenagers certainly at
the time it was released you go oh I'm
your kids and you know I I will always
take issue with the phrase boys will be
boys especially the way it tends to get
applied a lot of times these days but
there is a reason that term exists there
is a certain amount of acceptance that
people let me forget boys specifically
people in their youth that's when we
make our mistakes and we make our
mistakes in our youth so that we can
learn from the men mature as adults but
if we're still if we have become what
you've ran an age where we should be
adults and we're still making the
mistakes that one would expect a
teenager or twenty-something to be
making that becomes a problem
that becomes less we're watching people
on a on a journey of wherever they're
going to end up in their lives and it
becomes we're watching people who are
stuck in a rut that they are never gonna
get out of because they should have
gotten out of it by now and that is why
I feel this criticism of rent which I
think does apply to the movie but has
been unfairly pushed out to the entirety
you know the whole thing's like Oh rent
is done because of this well no it works
in the play cuz they're not in their 30s
in the play and it does make a
difference so those are my thoughts and
my sort of defense of a play that I love
and a film that I enjoy it at the time I
saw it but have have come to see this
problem with it but again I feel that
and if you want to apply that criticism
to the film mine
don't say that that means the play
doesn't work because that problem I
would argue doesn't exist on stage so
those are my thoughts on that I think
god I wish there was a date or something
that I could tie this into cuz this this
is gonna come out of nowhere but in any
case folks whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff you can do too because
there's links and there's buttons down
there check them out if you feel like it
there's a link to the patreon you know
if you like supporting me that way but
even if you don't
don't sweat it because at the end of the
day you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]